[Musique]
je suis à l'étudiée en soins infirmiers
parce que je voulais travailler dans le
Nord
je voulais partir à l'aventure le
déracinement vraiment vivre des
expériences hors du commun
l'immensité des paysages de la côte nord
Gabriel connaît
elle est infirmière à bord des avions
d'urgence médicale de la région et
accompagne les patients des petits
villages isolés vers blanc Sablons ou
sétile ou plus de services sont
disponibles
elle a été embauchée par une agence
privée et travaille à temps partiel sur
la côte nord tout en vivant près de
Montréal comme des milliers de
travailleurs ici elle fait du navet âge
communément appelée du flying flyout
c'est que ça permet d'avoir beaucoup de
temps libre donc on est appelé à
travailler beaucoup très intensément sur
des courtes périodes de temps pour après
ça être complètement
maître de notre tal
je dis ça ceci à l'industrie minière le
flying flyer dans la région faute de
main d'oeuvre locale en janvier 525
employés du centre de santé de la côte
nord était de la main d'oeuvre dite
indépendante comme Gabriel en majorité
des employés qui font du navetage ça
c'est mortel pour une ville comme cette
île que des gens d'extérieur viennent
travailler
ça contribue pas au dessus social et à
l'économie d'une ville la côte nord se
vide goutte à goutte 1400 résidents
l'ont quitté en cinq ans elle en compte
seulement
90405 aujourd'hui le flying flyout n'est
qu'une des raisons au revoir au niveau
des jeunes on le voit également au
niveau des retraités des retraités qui
pour des raisons qui leur appartiennent
vont décider de quitter la région de
cette île soit parce que les enfants ne
sont plus dans la région et qui sont
grands-parents et que leurs
petits-enfants sont à l'extérieur
l'époque où la qualité d'un projet se
jugeait par la quantité d'emplois
présentement elle est révolue la mission
de Paul Lavoie et d'attirer les
investisseurs assez t-il c'est certain
que on n'aime pas voir des situations
comme ça ou la population de notre
région diminue est-ce que c'est
inquiétant oui il veut s'attaquer en
priorité à la pénurie de logement un
problème accentué par le flying flyer et
qui nuit aussi au développement de la
région
un Catherine mi se loue facilement plus
de 1000 dollars par mois s'est-il et
encore faut-il en trouver un dans les
dernières années on ne sentit peut-être
une pression s'accentuer au niveau du
flying flyer et là on commence à le
sentir avec un déséquilibre au niveau de
nos capacités de logement
[Musique]
de Gabriel est ici à l'auberge de
jeunesse le tangon
[Musique]
elle adore son ambiance internationale
qu'elle retrouve peu ailleurs sur la
côte nord
au niveau des des festivals de la
culture du multiculturalisme des
restaurants il y aurait du travail à
faire elle a vécu à temps plein pendant
deux ans et demi à blanc Sablon un
village de 2100 habitants mais en 2021
elle est repartie vers le sud au niveau
professionnel j'avais envie d'essayer de
découvrir d'autres choses parce que
quand on est dans des petits milieux
comme ça il y a pas autant
d'opportunités que quand on est en ville
par exemple en faisant flying flyer je
me retrouve à avoir le meilleur des deux
mondes
c'est une des belles rivières à saumon
ici au Québec le maire de Port-Cartier
dont la ville est en déclin rêve de
mieux faire connaître les atouts de la
côte nord pour donner envie de s'y
installer encore faudrait-il selon lui
des enclavé la région tu veux
on parle d'un troisième lien à Québec on
a même pas un lien est-ce que ceux qui
favoriserait le développement
touristique rend accessible à base
totale jusqu'à blanc Sablon
ça MRC a financer un séjour exploratoire
pour une trentaine d'immigrants cet
automne Fanja était du groupe et la
maintenant à cette île depuis deux mois
ce magnifique livre on nous l'avait
offert le 22 septembre lors de notre
séjour nous avons été accueillis mais
d'une façon vraiment exceptionnelle je
sais tomber en amour de cette île
elle travaille maintenant pour un
organisme communautaire qui aide les
nouveaux arrivants sa famille viendra
bientôt la rejoindre
il y a une université tout ce qu'il faut
donc c'est suffisant je dirais pour
avoir une qualité de vie vraiment sur la
côte nord on rêve de multiplier ce genre
d'histoire pour renverser la tendance
qu'est-ce qui peut être fait pour
favoriser les gens à revenir en région
où est-ce qu'il y a des crédits est-ce
que Noël financière qui peut être
apporté au municipalités qui sont
ciblées dans certaines régions dit
éloignées par exemple pour pouvoir
donner un congé taxes pour la première
année
heureuse d'être devenu Nord côtière
Fanja rêve d'une maison au bord de la
mer
et que le soir je rentre chez moi avec
toute cette tranquillité et voir le
soleil se coucher
et coucher de soleil ici sont
magnifiques
Gabriel elle continuera de profiter de
la région à sa façon et je suis une
opportuniste professionnellement c'est
sûr j'ai masser la côte nord pour lui
souhaiter de se développer à sa juste
valeur
pour la beauté des paysages pour
l'infini pour la beauté du monde
finalement
[Musique]